hello everyone and welcome back to some
rapid action unleashes yesterday we
played a very nice game I was a sort of
um sort of a pet defense type of game no
sorry not a Petro the Alin defense type
of game uh although maybe we we reached
it through a different move order but in
the end I was able to use some of the
tactics that I use uh in the uh you know
my Adventures against the alakin to take
the win but there were moments where I
could have um tactically played better
but what are you going to do uh uh you
cannot uh you know affect how how your
tactics will work especially with um a
little time on the clock and like Blitz
or rapid and bullet but I'm I'm U you
know sensing that you guys are getting
uh some value out of these videos so I
will continue doing them if you guys uh
if you guys agree as I really am
enjoying making them uh rapid is is
really a completely different game than
bullet and Blitz uh the only the only
chest I ever played is pretty much
bullettin Blitz online so yeah these
rapid sessions are are are something
very enjoyable for me so uh let's
continue our opponent for this one uh
will be sorry not that uh we have to
create it like this so we get a stronger
opponent uh and our opponent for this
one will
be let's let's
see um we are currently at uh I think
2261 or maybe less yeah this is the yeah
this is the range that we are accepting
opponents 2261 to
2761 uh
not not a lot of people playing rapid 10
plus zero
obviously sometimes they just recreate
it and then we get an opponent right
away uh not sure yeah you guys always
said it's funny because I say okay last
game I had white this game I'll get
black and it's completely random you
know sometimes you actually will get too
wi in a row uh but yeah I I kind of
thought that it's always going to be uh
you know one game game black one game
white and our opponent is Mr queeb or
Mrs Quee rated 2431 opening with D4
we're going to stick with Knight to F6
as that's how we've uh played everything
it's a okay so it's a classical approach
I like it uh we're going to go for for
E6 and Bishop to B4 the nimzo Indian
will be on the board and he already has
his E3 line ready I'm going to play C5
he even pre moved this knight move uh
obviously it can be played to pretty
much everything and we're going to
pressure the
center okay so a trade on
C3 and we might even yeah we might even
land on Knight on
e4 just uh just so if he before he gains
control over D4
Square yeah and we're going to try and
uh okay so he trades
once uh perfectly fine fine do we do we
trade back right
away yeah if he
takes yeah he he might win a pawn here
but it's not I think a pawn that you can
keep so it's not really an issue like if
if he takes I'm going to capture back
and now if he takes I'm just going to uh
I'm not going to win it back right away
but I will win it back at some point
yeah we're going
to yeah what is this what is is this why
am
I why am I struggling to regain my Pawn
very
strange yeah
okay he does he does get the pawn for
the moment he will he will be able to
cement it with B4 but okay we will
undermine the pawns later on yeah I've
uh obviously messed something up here
obviously I've messed something up here
let's go Knight C6 I don't want to trade
Bishop for Bishop now that I'm down a
pawn but if he wants to trade Bishop for
knight uh yeah I'm done with that and he
will have to play B4 at some
point and we we're probably just going
to Castle and uh if plays B4 we're going
to charge with with
A5 yeah very very
interesting okay so he just defends
it makes sense makes sense definitely
he's preventing Bishop E6
also yeah okay we're just going to
Castle
here yeah he does he does have his Pawn
that's
uh very
interesting okay let's go
here yeah B B4 B4 is is is already in
the house and we're going to go Knight
E5 at least get something for our
position for for blundering that
pawn okay so we have to get our Knight
here he does have the strong Bishop but
uh I actually prefer my my knight here
okay so
he uh he locks it in but you know it's
not not really
much some C6 action might
happen uh and next he's going to attack
my uh my knight so we have to be ready
for that and he doesn't have any threats
for the moment so I'm just going to
position my queen in a way uh that I can
uh defend the Knight I want to play
Queen to G6 and have everything here
supporting my knight
and he will have to deal with this this
Knight for for the rest of the game and
on the other hand he does have the
bishop pair okay putting the king here
I'm not so
sure it's a very odd Square to put the
King
on
H very odd Square to put the King
on let's go Rook
C8 because now
I'm
yeah maybe it's uh maybe it's maybe it's
useful in some way that I don't
realize H so what I would really love to
do is to get my Rook somehow into the
game but it's not going to be easy like
if I play A6 he's just going to put the
bishop on A4 the bishop doesn't really
have uh any great purpose here and he
yeah F3 okay that's the reason why he
played it he wanted let play
F3 yeah but this is
uh not all that
impressive cuz now he can't take I will
just take and he can't take back because
of
Checkmate if he takes with the pawn sure
he can do that but then he he's prone to
all sorts of nasty discoveries and we
will win our Pawn
back uh but what's the best Discovery
that's the that's the real question
what is the best discovery that we
have
H yeah so many of them are possible but
uh opening up the C file
does seem to be the best
one yeah we're going to go for that and
now if he pushes I can just capture the
the pawn with the Knight
so
yeah I just take
it yeah not the best uh Pawn pushing
action yeah he he he missed that after I
capture here I will also be threatening
Checkmate after all of the Trad on D3
happen yeah okay so we we didn't just
win our Pawn back we we actually won a
pawn while doing all of this and now
it's time to figure out the proper way
to to play this because it's still not
it's not it's not like we're winning on
the spot he does have some Bishop action
here if plays Rook to G1 will be very
hard for us to
defend and uh yeah we have to figure out
we have to figure out a proper way of
handling things
here and I think it's Rook C2 Rook C2
because it threatens Checkmate if he
takes my Rook I will play Knight check
and pick up the
queen and and after Rook C2 if he plays
Rook to G1 I can just sacrifice The Rook
he's going to capture I'm going to play
Queen H3 check King G2 yeah Queen G3
check King H1 and queen to H3 Checkmate
so Rook to C2 is the
move yeah very nasty stuff very nasty
stuff yeah but it's not really yeah it's
not really fair that I get uh such a
such a wonderful uh tactical position
out of a position where I just blundered
a pawn in the opening or maybe I didn't
blunder it but I'm pretty sure I did
pretty sure I did yeah okay so he goes
for it we're going to sacrifice the rook
and Checkmate him uh that's
uh yeah that's the best way to do
it okay so he also has this but uh if he
goes uh here yeah okay now we don't go
here because of this so we have Bishop
to H3 check he has to go back and then
we can just Checkmate him
uh that that also works yeah I like this
this is fine all right so very nicely
done but uh more than the game I'm
interested in what was that what was
that silly what was what were those
silly moves that I made in the opening
so C5 um I mean you can play this pretty
much wherever he he Prem moved this
Knight to E2 move yeah he knows that
Knight E2 is best I play D5 okay I mean
there are so many so many variations
here that you can use uh yeah I played
Knight D4 right away yeah obviously
Knight D4 gets a question mark and an
exclamation mark As It blunders the pawn
so it's better to just uh take on C4 and
he will play D captures on C5 I'm going
to trade Queens King captures uh and now
just Knight here going after the pawn uh
whereas B4 is
impossible uh due to C captures and B3
alaan so here we just trade let's say
captures captures and it's uh equal
position so that's uh that's how you do
it uh really but I played Knight E4 and
he yeah he went for this he didn't go
for Knight captures on e4 okay so he
played it like this but it's still a
pawn yeah he still up a clean Pawn I
played Queen E7 he delivered a check I
blocked with the knight uh greedy but
you know what are you going to do queen
C2 I castled he played castles I played
Bishop F5 because I really wanted to get
my knight to this Square I thought he
might just capture the Knight to avoid
all of these problems but no he played
B4 uh I played Knight here and he played
Bishop to B2 yeah he his position is
actually remarkable yeah it's uh merely
a matter of him blundering that pawn
yeah King to H1 yeah it does get a
question mark and an exclamation mark H
but I think it's always best you know to
get both if you just get a question mark
then your move is weird if if there's an
exclamation mark as well uh you know
there might be something yeah I played
Rook to C8 and he now played F3 which is
still
great for him I played this and now he
just has to play Rook captures on F3
yeah that was the that was the mistake
but he played F captures and now Knight
captures on C5 is the is the equalizing
move but now Rook to G1 is the move and
we trade Queens yeah Rook to G1 I would
have to trade Queens he captures here
and I just move the Knight here attack
the bishop the rook and to defend my G7
pawn and it's a equal position so yeah I
blunder the pawn he blundered into an
equal position but then he got greedy
with d uh with E4 and after Knight
captures on e4 he's just lost uh he
played here so Queen H5 is best I played
Rook to C2 but yeah Rook to C2 also
completely winning plus five for me uh
yeah he has to give up the queen but he
played this and now it's just a mate in
three yeah Queen H3 check I
miscalculated it a little bit but um
yeah okay Queen H3 also mate in one I
don't know why I preferred the the
masking Bishop mate uh uh is is is the
first one that I checked and I saw it
was Checkmate so I went for that one uh
but yeah uh obviously I will have to
improve my knowledge of the nimso Indian
defense uh not a great way to blunder
upon in the opening but you know luckily
our opponent gave us a chance and we
were able to bounce back uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions uh and whatever else happens
in the Chess World uh so thank you all I
will see you soon and an excellent rest
of your
day